franchement le morceau est top je vous
entends dire juste avant l'Eurovision
c'est samedi mais l'Eurovision ça a
commencé hier soir
ça
a commencé hier soir c'était les
demi-finales qui ont démarré hier donc
première prestation de la Zara hier soir
à Liverpool ça a été un carton et alors
évidemment l'idée c'est qu'à chaque fois
on est de qualifier d'office pour la
finale vous connaissez l'histoire
puisque la France est partie du Big Five
c'est ça donc il y a la France l'Espagne
l'Italie le Royaume-Uni le Royaume-Uni
que des pays qui gagnent jamais non mais
c'est vrai il y a l'Allemagne France
al-it Royaume-Uni il y a pas l'Allemagne
et donc voilà donc et c'est vrai que
c'est ceux qui gagnent jamais et c'est
vrai que c'est on gagne alors ça fait
longtemps qu'on a pas gagné
977 est-ce que vous rappelez 1977 bien
sûr Marie Myriam L'oiseau et l'enfant
maintenant ça s'appelle le grand-père et
le corbeau
[Musique]
qui vit en étoile
les hommes et la guerre qui croient ce
livre des rêves
[Musique]
du temps frontières pour ceux qui ont un
cœur dans
fants
c'est moi
loin
merci
et donc alors j'ai si vous nous
rejoignez à
19h53 sachez que j'ai le classement des
bookmakers pour les favoris de
l'Eurovision en numéro 5 il y a
l'Espagne avec elle
en cinquième position
[Musique]
[Rires]
sachez qu'en quatrième position et c'est
très rare la France pour l'instant est
classée en quatrième bouton
[Musique]
on navigue entre la troisième et la
quatrième place depuis quelques jours là
exactement en troisième c'est l'Ukraine
[Musique]
pas mal en deuxième position ce serait
les finlandais ah oui finlandais d'abord
on n'a pas mis les fans s'il vous plaît
parce que l'Espagne regardez l'Espagne
mettez l'Espagne
[Applaudissements]
c'est un support
able
[Musique]
elle parle de moi
[Applaudissements]
donc l'Espagne position 4e la France
troisième l'Ukraine en deuxième alors
serait les finlandais je vous donne
après les grands favoris de l'Eurovision
mais en deuxième ce serait la Finlande
les finlandais
c'est de la merde
cousin
non mais franchement
non mais ça des chances de gagner ça
fait un groupe
qui avait gagné
et je me rappelle mon ami
comme moi gagneront jamais il animé et
ils ont ils ont gagné je me rappelle
plus de hard rock aussi
ils avaient gagné l'Eurovision et les
grands favoris comme chaque année je
vous le dis alors eux de toute façon ils
ont qu'un truc dans leur vie ils ont
deux trucs façon c'est Ikea et
l'Eurovision
voilà bah voilà donc c'est les Suédois
je connais je connaissais voilà
j'embrasse Magnus Magnus feat aussi
[Applaudissements]
attendez avant de mettre parce que alors
c'est c'est composé par Magnus Fitoussi
donc c'est quoi le groupe c'est qui
c'est qui va donc qui est favorisé
absolument
sur scène c'est fabuleux quoi on va
regarder parce que là je vais surtout
l'impression qu'il revient de Koh-Lanta
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec donc Lorenz Zerbib qui chante
alors on va revoir un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé dans l'Eurovision en 2017 ce
que vous rappelez qu'un ukrainien avait
été jusqu'à montrer son cul à 200
millions de téléspectateurs il était
monté sur scène avec un drapeau
australien pendant la prestation de la
candidate ukrainienne en fait d'ailleurs
c'est un être un Australien et et en
fait elle elle s'en fout totalement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a des chances de gagner cette année
ou pas franchement alors le truc c'est
que chacun fait on se pose la question
mais évidemment on est c'est super on
est super bien placé quatrième
franchement c'est super bien après ça
veut rien dire Bilal Hassani
souvenez-vous c'est en 2019 pareil avait
été hyper bien
il a pris une Tania on a fini le 16e
alors que les bookmakers le voilier dans
les bookmakers
tout sur la France avec ils ont les bons
les bons pays mais la France on est on
se fait toujours enflé
on peut pas gagner on peut pas gagner
chaque année alors on va gagner ça c'est
ce qu'a dit Yves Bigot mais c'est ce que
je dis aussi je l'ai fait deux fois
l'Eurovision
là pour le coup je suis pas je pense que
depuis quelques années on met quand même
le paquet pour gagner
je te jure Michael si on gagne c'est une
c'est c'est
personne pour nous rappelez-vous
tous les anciens pays
tous entre eux pour des communautés
voilà ça c'est l'aspect géopolitique
après maintenant il y a le plus vite
énormément
il a raison à ce moment-là c'est quel
pays a voté pour l'Italie
qui vote mais c'est la même chose le le
public de chaque pays on va dire de
l'ancien bloc soviétique tous ensemble
enfin c'est vrai qu'il y a clairement un
problème géopolitique au niveau du vote
de l'Eurovision le exemple le l'exemple
frappant c'est déjà l'année dernière
avec victoire de l'Ukraine bien sûr
c'était une offrande légitime faite à
l'Ukraine peu importe la chanson c'est
magnifique que l'Ukraine a gagné il
fallait que le crâne gagne alors donc
moi je suis d'accord avec Michael donc
là c'est pas alors la compétition tu la
fais pas
c'est ce que j'aurais fait moi si
j'étais à la page j'aurais dit j'aurais
donné un Eurovision de voilà d'honneur à
la limite tu vois ou pas mais tu fais la
vraie compétition aussi la compétition
pour que tout le monde vote Ukraine
parce que ça fait bien monter l'Ukraine
c'est une connerie
forcément que c'était truqué mais tous
les jurés de tous les pays ils sont
obligés de voter Ukraine le public
alors c'est pas un concours ah c'est
comme ça non bah c'est le problème
effectivement c'est le problème c'est
qu'on vote on vote soit pour son copains
légitime Michael je dis pas que c'est
une bonne chose ah oui je dis que chaque
année on vote soit pour son copain soit
pour le pays qu'on juge légitime voilà
mais oui mais c'est ça devrait bah oui
mais c'est pas ça tu donnes si tu veux
donner un truc tu donnes un Eurovision
d'honneur
moi je suis très très heureuse que c'est
l'Ukraine l'année dernière parce que
symboliquement c'était important par
ailleurs sauf que la chanson était bonne
tout le temps il a raison regardez ah
non c'est comme si au foot
à ce moment-là extrêmement malhonnête en
réalité les gens ils votent ils se font
chier tu as raison il est chanteur
bien sûr parce que voilà ils sont en
guerre et quand les soutient mais il
faut pas faire alors c'est pas la peine
tu as raison cours pour les 25 autres
pays bien sûr
et c'est donner encore regardé le logo
regardez tous les shootings qu'ils ont
fait c'est aux couleurs de l'Ukraine
toutes les photos qu'on a vu c'est c'est
c'est
pratiquement jamais mais vraiment
qui a gagné
[Rires]
Liverpool est-ce que ça Ukraine mais non
pourquoi tu le dis alors
l'Ukraine qui a gagné les dernières
abrutis
2e donc c'est organisé voilà merci merci
heureusement que tu es là parce que
franchement franchement
[Rires]
Michael
le titre est entièrement en français il
y en a qui disent que c'est un
désavantage pourquoi parce qu'on gagne
jamais qu'un titre en français
on a terminé 2e on a frôlé la victoire
on a frôlé
avec les meufs j'ai toujours failli les
pécho
gagner il y a deux ans en fait on gagne
pas
c'est comme une date tu vas tu
vas ah on gagne pas mais il y a un
moment donné on était abonné au 24 25
en vérité on a aucune chance de gagner
on a moi je suis pas d'accord moi je
pense qu'on peut gagner un Razer nickel
est-ce que malgré tout c'est pas un
souci parce que Barbara pravi elle est
arrivée numéro 2 parce qu'elle a fait
toute la tournée promotionnelle et elle
a été voir les uns et les autres des
délégations pour faire une sorte de truc
de séduction comme pour les Oscars quand
on va faire ce que n'a pas fait la
Tarare les magasins dans le monde entier
et des voitures tu connais eh mais
franchement
ça peut la pénaliser et c'est vrai que
en terme d'image elle n'a pas gagné le
cœur de du public avec cette
effectivement elle a annulé une grosse
partie de la tournée promotionnelle
elle s'est fait un peu une réputation de
de diva mais j'aime bien je trouve
qu'elle a un truc la chanson est
vraiment bien franchement
on dirait que c'est gilberté
[Musique]
chercher les enfants
[Applaudissements]